externalities
so so far in the class we once again
remember the big picture we started with
the first fundamental theorem of welfare
economics which is that the
competitive market will maximize total
social welfare
then we said that will not be true under
conditions of market failure remember
market failure doesn't mean market
collapse
it means that when there are barriers to
the market achieving
this first best outcome okay one barrier
is imperfect competition
one barrier was imperfect information
a third barrier to uh
to welfare maximization or a third
source of market failure
is externalities okay that's the third
source of market value we're going to
talk about that today
and what is an extra now we'll be very
clear about the definition
an externality occurs
whenever one party's actions makes
another party
better or worse off okay
let's do it look at any person whether
my actions make you
better or worse off but i don't bear the
consequences of that
so when my actions make you better or
worse off
but i don't bear the consequences then
there's an externality
okay so let's talk about that
in the context let's start with the
classic example of externalities
which is a negative production
externality
a negative production externality
okay the class example
is you've got a river on that river is a
steel plant
that steel plant produces steel okay
but as a byproduct of that production it
dumps sludge into the river
okay you guys remember the lorax it's
basically lorax okay
so basically the steel plant dumps
sludge into the river
okay that sludge floats down the river
and kills the fish
those killed fish mean that fishermen
cannot make as much money
fishing on the river okay
so basically there's sludge coming out
of the factory
okay and
that sludge we're gonna make the
assumptions directly proportional to
production of steel
so we say for every unit of steel
produced there's one unit of sludge that
emits from the factory
okay just make this model easy so every
unit of steel there's one unit of sludge
that sludge floats down the river and
kills the fish unfortunately there are
fishermen
down this river who are trying to catch
fish and that hurts their livelihood
okay so this is a classic example
of loading by an externality because the
steel plant's behavior
is imposing a cost on the fishermen
their sludge is the most caused the
fisherman but the steel plant doesn't
bear any consequence of that they just
dump the sludge and forget about it
okay so that's mean by negative it's a
negative externality because my actions
are hurting you
the steel plants actually are hurting
the fishermen it's a production
externality because it comes out of the
production process
in this case for steel so that's mean by
negative
production externality it means that
when
one party's production adversely affects
another party
but the party doing the production
doesn't bear any consequences of that
then that's a negative production
externality so what effect does that
have let's go to figure 22 1
and talk rapidly about how we think
about production externalities
okay this is the market for steel
if you're 21 is the market for steel the
quantity of steel on the x-axis the
price is still in the y-axis
okay the market is initially in
equilibrium point a
that is where demand which is the
downward sloping blue line equals supply
which is the upward sloping blue line
now as we said in a perfectly
competitive market
demand represents the marginal
willingness to pay
for the good which is equal to the
marginal benefit that consumers get from
consuming the good
okay the marginal benefit of consuming
the good is the marginal willingness to
pay
and that's what's represented by the
demand curve okay
we're not going to touch that here we're
going to leave that alone
okay the supply curve is the firm's
marginal willing supply which is their
marginal cost
okay so in the perfectly competitive
market where marginal benefit
equals marginal cost we get equilibrium
and that yields the welfare maximizing
outcome the market succeeds it does not
fail
okay the difference now is we're now
going to drive a wedge
between privately perceived benefits
and social benefits so for the
consumption of steel with the demand
curve
we're going to say the benefit to
individuals is the benefit to society
they're one in the same that's what
we've assumed all course
but for the supply of steel we're going
to say wait a second the benefit to
society
is different than a benefit to the steel
producers or i'm sorry the cost to
society
is different than the cost of steel
producers the cost steel producers
which is their private marginal cost is
supply curve
but the social marginal cost
is adds the damage they're doing to the
fishermen
that is society encompasses all the
actors in society
it encompasses both the steel plant and
the fishermen
so the co marginal cost society is the
cost of producing the steel
plus the marginal damage
being done to the fishermen so social
marginal cost
equals private marginal cost plus
marginal damage
social marginal cost that goes private
marginal cost plus the marginal damage
and we see that as the red line
okay what that means from a
welfare perspective what we care about
is social marginal benefits and costs
not private marginal benefits and costs
so what that means is the social optimum
the welfare maximizing optim is actually
at point c
point c is the left maximizing optim
where the social marginal cost
equals the social marginal benefit
okay and therefore we over
produce what's happening
is the steel company not considering the
damage they're doing through production
the fishermen
produces too much the steel company
produces at the point where private
marginal cost
equals private marginal benefit which in
our case equals social marginal benefit
okay that's the that's the private
market decision
but in fact it should be producing at
the point
where social marginal cost equals
private marginal benefit
private marginal but equals social
marginal benefit okay
and the point of so where social margin
costs equal social marginal benefit is
lower production why because
lower production avoids that reduces the
damage being done to the fishermen down
the river
okay so the optimum from society's
perspective
is point c in other words there is a
market failure the private market
is not delivering the welfare maximizing
outcome
and we could see that creates a
deadweight loss
the deadweight loss is the units that
are traded
that are socially inefficient why
they're socially inefficient they're
privately efficient
they're using q2 and q1 before we
introduce externalities we'd say well
it's a shame if they don't get produced
right
if you ignore sales would say the
institute q2 and q1 well they have a
benefit higher than their cost
so they should get produced but actually
in the world of accidentalities their
benefit is
lower than their cost because their cost
incorporates the damage done to the fish
so there's a deadweight loss critically
i don't know how to draw these
deadweight loss triangles remember
deadweight loss triangles always point
to the optimum the deadweight loss
triangle is the area abc
okay it's drawn its units that are sold
where the social marginal cost exceeds
the social marginal benefit
and that's that deadweight loss triangle
so there's an inefficiency
arising from the fact the private actors
do not account for the social
implications of their actions okay
questions about that so
we have a classic example perhaps the
classic example in all of economics
of a market failure the classic example
is a market failure happens
when the social implications of your
actions
okay uh are different than the private
implications
since people maximize their own private
well-being that's what adam smith sort
of taught us
the notion of the invisible hand is that
the market acting in its own interests
will deliver the best outcomes for
society we're saying no that's not true
if the market is own interest has
implications for other parties
that are not accounted for
okay now
externalities don't have to just be on
the
uh production side we can also have
negative consumption
externalities
that would be a case where my literally
consuming a good
makes you worse off
my consuming a good makes you worse off
okay so let me start with a simple
question
let's start with a perfectly competitive
market
if i consume a good i raise demand for
that good
that raises the price is that an
externality
in a perfectly competitive market it's
not why isn't that an externality
if i consume the if i want to consume
the good the price goes up everyone pays
a higher price
why is that not an externality yeah
because you also bear the costs and
accidentally only occurs when you don't
bear the cost of your actions
when you want a car and therefore the
price of cars goes up
you pay that higher price accidentally
only occur when you don't bear the
consequences
so in general could some checklists
don't happen through causing higher
prices
because substitutionalities happen more
directly when my consumption affects you
so the best example this would be
smoking
okay when i smoke it affects you
it affects you a number of ways most
directly if i smoke in this classroom
you get secondhand smoke and you get ill
as a result
but that's not all it affects you
because
if i smoke and i get sick
and my health care costs go up
then while i work at mit all my fellow
mit employees bear those costs because
we all share health insurance
and when i retire all society bears
those costs because those costs are paid
for by the medicare program
which is financed by taxation
so my health care costs are an
externality secondhand smoke's an
externality
what are some other exodus from smoking
what are other externalities that can
then occur can occur from smoking yeah
environmental damage from the production
well that would be a production
externality
okay we're gonna leave that alone for
now i'm just talking about from
consuming cigarettes
from consuming cigarettes what else what
other damage comes so i make you i
make you sick through secondhand smoke i
might raise health care costs
i might raise health care costs okay
what else do their externality what else
does smoking
do
well turns out there are 100 000 this is
a number which i triple check
because i still can't believe it 100 000
people
every single year die in fires caused by
smokers
not in the u.s worldwide which is a
crazy number but if you think about
how tightly plaque slums are in
developing countries
one person falling asleep with their
cigarette burning can kill thousands of
people
okay that is an externality because my
action
to smoke has killed you okay i'm clearly
not going to compensate you for that
so that's another externality okay
what about the fact that smokers are
less productive at work
they have to take more smoke breaks they
might get sick more often
is that an externality or not
the fact that smokers are less
productive at work is that external or
not
why or why not yeah not necessarily
because if they're less productive they
might do less work and get paid less
exactly it's not an externality if
they're paid less
this is the key thing okay which is only
excellent if you don't bear the
consequences smokers are less productive
at work
and they get paid less as a result by
exactly the same amount they're less
productive
there's no externality but if their wage
doesn't fully adjust
and therefore the law of productivity
affects everybody else in the firm or
the firm's profits that is an
externality
okay so this is the deep aspect of
externalities you have to think about
whether
people are compensating for it okay
you have to think about that okay most
importantly
the fact i kill myself
by smoking is not an externality
okay smokers die seven years earlier on
average
roughly speaking every cigarette you
smoke lowers your life by seven minutes
it's pretty linear okay
but you know what if i sit by myself on
a rock in the middle of nowhere and
smoke till i die
no problem
because in that case the social
implications are the private
implications
i've made my privately optimal decision
and there's no effect on anybody else so
it's also socially optimal
there's only externality if we have one
of these mechanisms like if and smoking
i'm in the woods and i started firing
the fire
company has to come that's an
externality but as long as i just sit by
myself and i don't i don't bother
anybody
smoke till i die there's no
externalities okay
so exercises come through the effects on
others so let's think about
the externals of smoking let's think
about a negative consumption externality
okay here we have the market for
cigarettes
on the x-axis we have the num i'm sorry
figured 22-2
on the x-axis we have the number of
cigarettes quantity cigarettes
consumed on the y-axis we have the price
of cigarettes per pack
we have initial equilibria point a which
is where
the private marginal benefit
equals the private marginal cost here
we're going to assume there's no
externalities from producing tobacco
let's assume there's no sludge produced
whatever
that's a separate issue okay there may
be production externalities too we
covered those you already know how to
think about those
here but here let's assume there aren't
any let's assume the social marginal
cost equals a private marginal cost no
production externalities
but there is a consumption externality
every cigarette i smoke is bad for
society
what that means is the social marginal
benefit is below the private marginal
benefit
the social marginal benefit is the
private marginal benefit minus marginal
the marginal damage i'm doing md's the
marginal damage
the marginal damage i'm doing that's
estimated to be about
absent secondhand smoke the damage for
smoking is about 50 cents a pack
the second hand smoke part is really
hard uh
uh and the estimates are anywhere from
one cent to two dollars per pack
so that's hard to know how big that is
okay but
certainly um uh we have we have
this negative consumption externality
which is that basically
um the every pack of cigarettes i smoke
is worth at least 50 cents less to
society than it's worth to me
because i'm have these external effects
in society and perhaps a lot
more than that as a result i should
smoke i choose to smoke at point a
but the social optimum is point c so
once again i've created a deadweight
loss once again i'm over
consuming there's over consumption here
just like there's over production seals
over consumption
and a dead weight loss because they're
units that are privately optimal to
consume
but not socially optimal
okay now um
externalities this is kind of a fun
topic because it is interesting i talked
so let's talk for a second about
secondhand smoke and whether that's
actual externality
so almost all the damage taken at smoke
is not done by smoking in a crowd it's
done to family members
almost all the damage taken in smoke is
done to family members mostly it's that
you make your family members sick by
smoking
is that an externality when or when is
it not an extra under what conditions
might it not be an externality
yeah well i guess it wouldn't be an
externality if like let's say you die
and then the consequences of them
getting sick doesn't affect you at all
or well obviously no no no no that would
be okay so what under what conditions
under what conditions would it not be
externally when so
yeah if you're like if your family gets
sick
yeah if i care about my family in
particular if i maximize
family utility that's not an externality
if my if i maximize not my usually my
family's utility
then i will essentially internalize
[Applause]
internalize the externality
just like a lower wage means that i bear
the consequences for being a less
productive worker
okay if i care about my whole family's
happiness
and i make my kids sick by smoking
then my smoking decision will actually
reflect the total consequences for my
family
i will smoke only if thoughtful for my
family for me to do so it doesn't mean i
won't smoke
it just means i must i'll have to enjoy
it enough that it's worth
making my kids sick okay it doesn't mean
that's an
incorrect decision because after all the
odds are you know make your kids that
sick and
you know you might like smoking a lot
okay it's just that
you will internalize the external
because you only smoke to the extent
that it is optimal for the whole family
so it's not necessarily an externality
okay so we'd like actually to test
whether it's an external there's
actually a clever test of this
which is there's a test of whether
people maximize family utility
which is if people maximize family
utility
what would be the implications of giving
a father a dollar versus giving a mother
a dollar
if both the father and the mother are
maximizing a family utility function
the same family utility function then
should it matter whether i give a dollar
to a father a dollar to a mother
no it shouldn't because it's a dollar to
the family we're maximizing family
utilities up to a family budget
constraint
it shouldn't matter who gets the dollar
so one test of family utility
maximization is
does it matter who gets the money and it
turns out it does a lot
okay so there's a great test of this
they um
in the uk these have a tax system
where essentially uh the way there was a
credit they gave for every kid
and the way the credit worked is there'd
be a check sent home
okay then they changed it so instead
they said well instead of sending a
check home we're just going to add it
into pay into wages
so instead of getting a check sent home
we're just going to raise your wages
well it had no effect on family budgets
they literally just changed it the
difference was
back in this in the 70s men worked and
women didn't
so when the check came home women
controlled it
but was in wages men controlled it so if
there's family utility maximization it
shouldn't matter
but it turned out as soon as they
changed the way they paid it spending on
kids went down and spending on drugs and
alcohol went up
because basically guys don't care about
kids as much as women do sorry guys
it's just i don't know i don't know what
the evolutionary biology is at least in
the 70s they didn't
so that's sort of a rejection of family
utility maximization who had the dollars
actually mattered it's kind of a neat
study
for how you think about these about
these theories so it suggests that
secondhand smoke probably people don't
perfectly maximize family chills there
probably are some externalities
okay so that's uh so that's a negative
consumption externality
there can also of course be positive
externalities
so let's talk about a positive
consumption externally
let's talk about my neighbor i don't get
along with my neighbor
okay um and partly it's because my
neighbor
has a habit of starting big projects and
leaving them half done
and about 25 years ago 20 years ago he
started a big project to landscape his
yard
created these huge mounds of dirt that i
look at directly from my kitchen and
then stopped
so for 20 years i've had to stare at
huge amounts of dirt
okay now um
let's think about my neighbor's decision
to go and get rid of those piles of dirt
let's say that that would cost one
thousand dollars
so the cost is a thousand dollars
okay and let's say the benefit to my
neighbor
from doing so is clearly less than a
thousand dollars we would have done it
let's say it's 800 so that's why he
leaves those piles of dirt
because the cost is a thousand dollars
to remove them it's only worth injured
to him
but what he's not accounting for is if
he removed them
there'd be positive benefit to me
of another 300
so actually the total social benefit of
removing the dirt piles
is higher than the social cost from a
social perspective he should do it
but he doesn't because privately it's
not optimal to do so
okay so that is a positive
consumption externality yeah does this
mean you'd be willing to pay him like
200
to do it well this leads to a very deep
question
which is can't all externality simply be
internalized let's take this example
why can't i just go over an offer to pay
him
okay well and in fact with any example
we can do that why can't the fisherman
just go pay the steel plant
okay why can't you pay me not to smoke
in class
okay indeed with any of these
externalities the question why can't
they all be internalized
and indeed there's a school of thought
which suggests that exercises aren't
real a problem they can all just be
internalized
but of course that's totally wrong okay
let's start with a hard example
let's talk about the biggest
environmental
externality which is global warming okay
with global warming okay every tangle
time you drive
you are bringing people of bangladesh
that much closer to being underwater
how could you possibly negotiate that
how could you possibly negotiate where
the people of bangladesh would come and
say we'll drive a little bit less so i
don't go underwater
okay that's not happening okay but even
with these simple cases think about this
why can't i just go to my neighbor and
offer 200 bucks
there's three problems first problem is
there's uh the fact that
i don't really know what his costs are
and what his benefits are
and that i might i don't want to offer
more than i have to to get him do it
okay the second problem is he don't know
how it doesn't know how i feel so it's
an information asymmetry
which makes negotiations hard the third
problem too which is it'd just be deeply
weird to do that
right i mean it's just not how society
works you think about a class case of an
external you probably all run into
with your neighbor playing their music
too loud
okay if your neighbor plays their music
too loud that is an externality
on you okay now in principle
you go to your neighbor and say well
look i'm studying for a test
this test will raise my grade by 10
points a higher grade
in this class will raise my earnings by
a thousand dollars
so i'm willing to pay you 83 to stop
playing music
because i've calculated my lifetime
earning effect you're playing the music
okay even at mit okay that'd be sort of
deeply weird to do
so what do you do you either shut up
about it you go yell at them
okay but yelling induces is an honestly
efficient way to resolve it because
maybe they really want to play the music
the efficient thing would be if it's
worth more than eight three dollars then
to play the music they should get to pay
it and just pay you 83
but in fact that doesn't work so in fact
private solutions these problems simply
do not work
okay it's just hard to figure out how
you can really get people privately
to internalize uh these um
uh these externalities okay because
negotiation is difficult because there's
just socially awkward
there is a famous apocryphal story told
of a famous economist
who was on a flight want to get work
done and couldn't because the person
actually wouldn't stop talking
so they actually offered them 10 bucks
to shut up uh i don't believe that
actually happened but
you know makes for a good story okay so
that's a positive consumption externally
finally we have positive production
externalities
the classic example positive production
externality
is um r d by private firms
okay when a firm does research and
development
they don't just create learning for
themselves they create learning that
might benefit other firms as well okay
and indeed the best economic estimates
suggest that the social returns to a
dollar of r d
are two and a half times the private
returns that every dollar of r d a firm
does
benefits society by two and a half times
how much it benefits the firm
and as a result firms under invest in r
d
okay as well firms under invest in r d
okay uh and they are and that's leading
them
to uh that's leading to too little r d
being done in society that affects all
of us because that affects growth
that's what my new book jumps starting
america is all about is about why we
need the government to come in
and invest more in our because firms
under invest okay essentially firms
don't account for the spillovers
that their investments have on others so
a great example used in the book
is the example of when two drug
companies were racing to invent statins
you guys are too young to know about
statins but statins are basically a
cholesterol lowering drug that's a
miracle it saves hundreds of thousands
of lives every year that says about 200
000 lives a year are saved by people
lowering the cholesterol for being on
statins
statins are being invented in the early
1980s by two rival drug companies
merck in the us and senko in japan they
were racing developed these statins
and then thank you suddenly stopped and
merck found out to the great finance
because some dogs got sick
in drug truck in the animal trials and
so merc went to thank you and said hey
where's the dog what's going on say he
said we're not going to tell you
you're our competitor so murk offered to
pay the money they offered to partner
sake you said no way
this is private r d we don't want to
share it with you so merc stopped too
five years later some academics got
permission to run trials on statins
turns out that what happened the dogs
had nothing to do with the drug
they were fine it's totally safe and
statins were invented
and save on 200 000 lives a year but
five years after they should have
literally one million people died okay
because there was they could not benefit
from the spillovers of r d knowledge
okay this is an example and by under
investment in r d
okay so we have x analysis to be
negative or positive the q production
side or consumption side
questions about that yeah so regardless
if they're negative or positive
externalities still create that weight
loss yes we're also negative or positive
everybody says
still create deadweight loss because if
they're positive i should um
um jason just send me a note next year
next year we should have in the handout
a positive
threat well i'll just do it here i can
i'm i'm not i'm capable of drawing graph
so let's say about r and d okay here's
the quantity of r d
okay here's the cost of r d the price of
r d
so basically and here's the the um
here's the uh so here's going to be the
demand for r d
okay here's good demand which is private
marginal benefit
and here's the uh here's the supply
which is the private marginal cost okay
and let's just say that there's no
excellence from actually th
this is a consumption exercise this is
this is a production externality
so basically the point is that when a
firm does r d
they do until the benefits to the firm
okay
equal the cost to the firm so they do an
optimal they do an amount of r d
of uh you know q1
okay at a price of p1 now but what
they're missing
is that in fact what they're missing is
that the cost
to them are actually well below
uh well below what it truly cost because
they are benefiting others by doing it
okay so the supply curve the pri
the the true social supply curve is down
here the social marginal cost
is the private marginal cost minus the
social benefits
that we get from doing that r d so as a
result
they should be doing q2 r d but they're
not
they're doing too little r d and that's
making a deadweight loss
the deadweight loss remember is with
reference to the optimal point
this is the deadweight loss this
deadweight loss from under producing
um r d the difference between uh
no i'm sorry i got that wrong this is
always triangle's always confusing i got
that wrong
okay it's the difference between the
social marginal cost between the social
marginal cost
and the private marginal benefit so
basically
let me think about this for one second
it's always a little bit hard to do so
basically their units
they their units they under produce so
essentially
what they're they should be producing
this many units
yeah between the with the private margin
yeah
it says i hit it right that's the
deadweight loss
okay yeah so basically what you have is
you're going to have
under production of r d just like you
had over production of steel
okay yeah uh why would the social
marginal costs go down
marginal benefit because this the
marginal benefit is
what's the marginal benefit of another
dollar of r d
that's that's basically that's
essentially what's the knowledge created
okay you could you could view this
either way but the idea here is
i'm producing r d i'm not consuming r d
this is the benefit of consuming r
d this is sort of the benefit side of
consuming that r d this is the use so
you think it was lowering the cost of
producing the r d
is sort of the way we think about it
okay but the main thing is not
is not yeah so is the the marginal
change between the
social curve and the private curve is
that
linear or as it grows that that's a
great question i'm always making it
i'm making a constant i'm assuming
marginal damage marginal damage or
marginal benefits are constant
mathematically whichever triangle you
choose is the same
yeah exactly because because i'm making
constant in fact you could imagine it
could be growing or shrinking
okay now with this in mind
and realizing the private sector can't
solve this for the reasons we talked
about
let's talk about the role let's talk
about
the role of government government
solutions
so once again remember the basic logic
of this class
which is that um the basic lodge of the
class
which is that um if uh
the ethos of the class is that the
market knows best
unless there's a market failure if
there's a market failure the private
market will deliver deadweight loss
now we have to ask can the government
actually make it better remember we
talked about monopoly regulation the
government may or may not make it better
okay infrared information asymmetries
that may or may not make it better same
thing with externalities the government
may not make it better so let's say how
the government in theory
could make it better okay well there's
two ways the government could make it
better
one way is by regulation so go back to
figure um
22-1 okay
the government could literally regulate
and could say look
we know the optimal level of steel to be
produced as q2
we're just going to tell you you produce
q2 that's it
problem solved okay we just say hey
steel plant
we know that optim's q2 you produce q2
problem solved
the problem with that is that requires
the government to know quite a lot
the government needs to know both the
supply and the demand curves
to figure out where q2 is and what they
should regulate
let's say all the government knows is
the damage being done and let's say the
damage is linear they can approximate as
linear
then there's a much easier solution
which is a corrective tax
what if the government came in and said
look i don't know where demand and
supply curves are
i don't really know it's really hard to
figure it out all i know is that
for every unit of steel you produce
which is you know sludge you're killing
a hundred dollars worth of fish that's
what i know that i can study
environmentally
okay what if i simply tax the steel
plant
by a hundred dollars for every unit of
steel they produced that if i imposed a
tax
on the steel plant
one unit of steel is one unit of sludge
in this example so i'm going to tax
every unit of steel they produce
which is which which is the sales
pricing wanting you to sludge
okay what if i impose that tax well
let's look at figure 22
3. what does that do to the firm's
decision
okay well before the government came in
the firm was producing at point a
where their private margin cost equal
the private marginal benefits which is
the social marginal benefit
now the government comes in and levies a
tax
it levies a tax of exactly md the
marginal damage
what does it do it shifts their private
marginal cost curve
to the social marginal cost curve it has
caused the firm to internalize the
externality
because now the firm is paying an amount
exactly equal to the damage they're
doing to society
so a corrective tax can cause the firm
to internalize the externality
correct attacks cause the firm to
internalize the externality
okay essentially corrective tax by the
government
can get us to the right answer because
it gets firms do the right thing
okay gets firms to pay attention to
social costs not just
the uh not just the private costs
okay similarly the same thing with a
positive externality
what could the government do with a
positive externality
yeah it could subsidize by exact so
imagine i knew exactly how much
social benefit there was per unit of r d
if i subsidized the firm doing r
d then i would lower their costs right
if i offered them a subsidy of this
amount
their cost curve would shift down
although the costs are indeed we get to
the right point
so a corrective tax of the amount of
damage
gets firms to internalize the
externality a corrective
subsidy of that amount gets firms to
internalize the externality
or individuals to exercise the
internality
and we can get to the optimal outcome by
the government imposing a corrective tax
or subsidy of the right amount
now we can of course also get there with
regulation it's just a lot harder
okay questions about that
okay this is our first example
of good taxes okay taxes have been bad
throughout this course the role of taxes
has been
has been distortion to the economy we
haven't talked about a lot we'll talk
about it more in a couple lectures
they've been distortion entered the
economy this is saying no
a tax can actually play a positive role
because a tax can correct
a market failure now as always if the
tax is said incorrectly it could make
things worse
okay if said a tax that was five times
the marginal damage you'd make things
worse
but if you said it correctly it can make
things better we're offering the
potential
for government intervention to make
things better here questions about that
okay so what do we have we have a
situation where the private market is
not delivering
the optimal outcome the prime minister
of the optimal outcome
where it seems hard to think of private
solutions
but where a government solution is
through regulation or easier corrective
taxation
can get us to the optimal outcome so now
let's ask how does this actually work in
practice
and let's talk about two examples let's
talk about environmental externalities
and health externalities
start with environmental externals and
of course the most important
is global warming okay uh
currently the amount of carbon dioxide
the atmosphere is at its highest level
in 400
000 years uh
basically every year becomes the hottest
year on record almost linearly almost
monotonically every year is the hottest
year on record
we're heating up scientists predict uh
that it's possible
the central prediction is that
temperatures will rise by more than two
degrees fahrenheit by the end of the
uh but i'm sorry by more than two
degrees celsius by the end of the
of the um of the century but it could be
more than that
there's actually currently the best
estimate is that
there's there's a all there's as much as
a 10
chance that temperatures go up by 10
degrees by the end of the century which
would end human life
basically in most of the world okay
there's a non-trivial chance
we're all gone by 200. not my problem
largely not your problem
certainly your kid's problem okay okay
by and large we are basically uh we are
basically
we have a we know for sure there's gonna
be negative implications
basically we are essentially unless
unless there's a radical new
technology invented bangladesh is gone
it's over for bangladesh
cape cod is gone much of florida is gone
that's already happening
okay at this point the question is can
we actually stop
the entire east and west coast and much
of the south from disappearing as well
and many other countries in the world
from disappearing
okay that's the sort of decision we have
to make now
okay so basically this is a classic
negative externality because
that negative situation you were not
thinking about that when you filled up
your car last time
you're not thinking about the fact the
fossil fuels you're emitting are
contributing to that
okay it's a classic negative externality
so what can the government do well the
natural solution would be corrective
taxation
the natural solution would be to have a
carbon tax
to literally say this is the amount we
actually have a pretty good sense from
from engineering models what the cost of
carbon is what the marginal cost of
carbon is
okay and we could literally impose a tax
on the use of carbon of that amount
i think it would amount to something i
don't know the numbers these days it's
something like between 25 and 50 cents a
gallon of gas
so it's a lot but it's not we've seen
gas prices in the last year go up and
down by that much
okay that's not an outrageous amount
okay
in europe they already have gasoline
taxes well above that level
okay so corrective taxation in principle
could be the answer we could literally
just use engineering models to compute
the cost social cost of carbon
we could put a tax on it and then at
least we would
stop global warming going forward you
know bangladesh may be gone
but we can maybe save a lot of the rest
of the world okay
so that's um that's in theory in
practice
in 1994 bill clinton proposed a three
cent gas tax
and lost congress okay in practice
people don't like gas taxes uh it's very
hard politically in the u.s and other
places
and that is why the world has turned to
a different approach
which is quantity regulation which is
say look
in practice we should have a global
carbon tax
in theories of global heart attacks in
practice that's hard that's why we have
uh negotiations that's why we try to
have a global negotiation
to try to get a global cap on carbon
emissions actually have a quantity
regulation
okay to actually have a quantity
regulation uh we started this the first
true global negotiation was in kyoto
japan
in december 1997
i was fortunate enough to be there for
that negotiation i was in the clinton
administration at the time
and um uh we got to uh go over and do
that negotiation was actually pretty
neat because
they decided i was going the last minute
and the only plane left to go on was air
force two
so i had to fly over the vice president
on air force two which was pretty cool
super cool they have really nice seats
and stuff and so i sat down on the phone
next to me rang
i was like i think i was like hello like
hey john i'm like oh my god
it was i'm calling from japan but like
getting a personal phone call and
playing was super cool
um so anyway so went over to kyoto i
learned how these negotiations work
which is uh over
five days i slept four hours um they in
japan they sell
um they sold the time this coffee and
cans so you just chug these cans of
coffee all the time
and stay awake and basically everyone's
so tired by the angel's degree just to
kind of get out get it done
and that's the way the negotiations work
um so we agreed
to the kyoto global warming treaty which
would have lowered emissions
worldwide but the u.s did not sign on
the u.s
refused to sign on there's been
continuing negotiations most recently we
know about the paris round of
negotiations
which us did sign on to but the current
administration has pulled this back out
of
so we have a problem which is that
basically we're heading to this
environmental
environmental catastrophe and the world
can't agree on
um actions to take uh and
you know uh it's not it's not really a
choice
and we have to do something uh or or
we'll or our grandkids will all be under
water
or great cancer cancers will all be
under water we have to do something
um the optimistics case that will do
something comes from the
example of what's called
chlorofluorocarbons when i was a kid
many many products were made what's
called chlorofluorocarbons they were in
refrigerators
they were in aerosol sprays etc
scientists realized they were actually
damaging the ozone layer which protects
us from ultraviolet rays from the sun
and we were like yeah whatever much like
they are with global warming now yeah
whatever but then
a [ __ ] hole opened up in the ozone
layer like literally it's like oh my god
there's a hole in the ozone layer and
180 countries got together almost
overnight and banned chlorofluorocarbons
like literally almost overnight they
were gone it was amazing
international cooperation of terrific
international cooperation to take an
environmental catastron and deal with it
the problem is global warming doesn't
quite work that way okay by the time
we say oh my god bangladesh is
underwater it's too late
so the question is sort of how do we get
politicians and the public interested in
taking something on
we don't have the symbol like a hole in
ozone layer to actually
represent the damage that's being done
and that is the challenge of facing
something like global warming but we
have to take it on
okay so that's environmental
externalities the other big type of
externalities are health externalities
our health externalities i talked about
smoking but indeed there are huge
externalities levied by a bunch of
activities that we do that impact our
health
so for example drinking drunk driving
causes 13 000 deaths per year
13 000 deaths per year okay to put a put
to put a sort of blunt face on it four
911s every year
from drunk driving okay plus 400
000 injuries every year for people
driving drunk
um consuming gasoline global warming
okay is a huge externalities um perhaps
one of the biggest
exercises facing us the biggest social
externality is obesity
okay obesity causes a lot of illnesses
uh that cost a lot of money um
projections are that children born in
the year 2000 so about about your kid
about your generation um one-third of
them will get diabetes before they die
okay based on current weight projections
now as you notice looking around this
room
that's not a problem of the elite east
coast people okay
it's not a problem it's a problem the
less educated it's problem concentrated
more in the south
okay but nonetheless it's if you look at
a number of southern states the obesity
rate is above 35 percent
literally more than one in three people
in the state are obese
okay this is a huge problem and it's
going to cause huge
social if that's huge social
consequences for our country the
question is what do we do about these
what are the things like smoking and
drinking
and obesity and there's essentially um
there's essentially uh four answers
the first is information
can we just inform people about the
damages and indeed this has been shown
to work
with smoking okay we knew smoking was
bad for you about
in 1954 okay but we only really got
through to people
starting really in the 1970s and 80s but
it's had enormous effect
smoking's fallen incredibly in the u.s
to that information but here's the
interesting thing
okay smoking rates smoking used to be 50
percent
in the entire every adult the fifth year
out smoke didn't matter race gender
class whatever
now smoking essentially down to zero
among the well-educated and still about
twenty percent
unless educated so information works
but only works in a very uh inequitable
way
okay so information is one solution the
second solution
is taxation
and indeed this has been shown to work
for cigarettes once again
smoking is price sensitive the
elasticity of smoke with respect to the
price is about minus 0.4
about every 10 you raise the price of
cigarettes there's about four percent
less smoking
it works in particular youth smoking
is very price sensitive use are very
priceless because you
have less money so they're very price
sensitive
so you so so it actually works um
but that's sort of the easy case tax
cigarettes is easy because every
cigarette's bad for you
taxing alcohol is trickier because after
almost the damage is done by a tiny
share of drinkers
most of us will consume alcohol
responsibly most of our lives
and not cause any external damage okay
but most of the damage is done by tiny
shared drinking so taxes is trickier
if i approach the big resident alcohol
taxes you'll say wait a second i'm a
responsible drinker why are you taxing
why you taxing me so that's a little bit
trickier not to mention obesity taxing
food is maybe the trickiest of all
okay so taxes are trickier you could
maybe try
an alternative thing you could do as
penalties so instead of taxing alcohol
we could just steep in the penalties for
drunk driving
you know if you killed a few drunk
drivers it'd be less drunk driving
okay but the problem is that's a pretty
extreme penalty and what if you got it
wrong you feel kind of bad about killing
someone
because the breathalyzer didn't work
there was a series of articles actually
new york times about how terrible
breathalyzers are
and how inaccurate they are okay so
problem with penalties is we can't
enforce them perfectly
okay so that's the third solution the
final solution the one that's really
most discussed right now
is illegality what if we just made these
things illegal and this comes to
the discussion of marijuana should
marijuana be legal
okay well illegality is an extreme form
of lowering externalities now obviously
when pot's illegal people still smoke
pot
but it's still true when you make it
legal it's consumed at much higher
levels
okay legality does matter so for example
you've done studies
yes people under 21 drink but literally
to look at people the day after the 21st
birthday they drink much more than the
day before their 21st not on the 21st
birthday that's the party we ignore that
but the day after the 21st birthday and
thereafter they're drinking at much
higher levels than before
legality matters okay it's also true the
day after 21st birthday people are much
more likely to die in a drunk driving
accident than the day before their 21st
birthday
okay so legality matters so the point is
we have a whole series of tools
to think about this and the question is
how should we combine and use them
and the answer is take 1441
and i'll teach you all about it but we
don't have any more time here
this just raises the issues to think
about with externalities it's an
important topic to think about i realize
it's a lot to cover in one lecture
i just want to sort of give you a taste
for how economists think about analyzing
this kind of market failure
you